on conçoit re bonsoir tweetie bonsoir
thiès point corps bonsoir tout le monde
nous sommes tous là voilà alors pourquoi
nous je suis là et vous êtes là aussi
mais bon nous formons nous nous formons
un groupe donc nous sommes tous là et
nous allons nous allons faire quoi
d'ailleurs
eh bien nous allons faire le tournoi
mensuel alors attendez on va alors
battus avec le chargeur c'est le vrai
qu'il est plus beaucoup de batteries
dans un premier temps en fait on va
faire des choses bien on va mettre ça on
va ouvrir lé chat on va faire ça on va
on va aux c'tés en fait on va faire les
choses on va faire des choses très très
bien vous savez quoi
on va faire des choses calmement on
arrivait juste un poil en avance pour
bien faire les choses
alors mon chargeur n'est plus branché à
l'électricité mais c'est de nouveau show
voulons pas tomber en panne
nous allons bien faire les choses allons
ouvrir le chat which nous allons offrir
le ouvrir le chacha ce point comme nous
allons tout ouvrir nous allons tout
ouvrir et nous serons donc prêt pour le
stream qui va pouvoir partir très
bientôt
donc nous allons ouvrir ceci nous allons
ouvrir le papa août qui est ouvert dès
maintenant le papa route est ouvert le
chat est là on va vérifier la raison que
tout est là j'ai l'impression que
absolument tout est là et la raison que
mon téléphone ça nous allons les voir le
téléphone mais nous allons tout ouvrir
en premier nous répondrons après nous
sommes tranquilles
nous avons le temps nous sommes en paix
alors on va faire ça maintenant on va au
stella chaîne sur la chaîne bitstream
on va faire les choses très calmement et
très bien
vous me sentais calme ils ont fait roast
nous allons tester au final le voilà
nous sommes nous nous sommes sur la
chaise vide stream donc automatiquement
nous sommes au dessus de tout donc nous
avons vers ceux ci nous allons vérifier
que ça marche
alors je dis nous mais je suis seul
donc bisri vous héberge pourront
spectateurs c'est une très bonne chose
et maintenant nous allons aller sur le
chat de check point comme tv tout en
douceur et nous allons voir une pub
normalement je vois une pub très
intéressante estime plus pour un nouvel
ordinateur et comme vous le savez j'ai
besoin d'un nouvel ordinateur
donc on est en train de me passer une
pub qui objectivement peut m'intéresser
donc là je suis très intéressé et je
vois ma tête sur chaque point comme
tesla htv est donc je suis heureux
maintenant que ceci est fait nous allons
leur rapetisser et nous allons garder
que le chat
donc nous sommes partout à et nous avons
fabien aussi ce soir que je vois dans le
chat en le lisant
c'était peut-être lui qui m'appelait ce
qui n'était pas prévu
alors nous appelons fabien nous avons
leçon à l'eau
salut femme tu n'étais pas prévu fap
n'était pas prévu nous ne savions pas
que tu seras là mais tu es la méta
cameron
mais ta caméra de leur de trop spécial
aujourd'hui je suis en grande forme
donc je vais tenter une autre notion
très bien géré associant très
intéressant c'est effectivement
effective
effectivement je lisais des vidéos juste
avant les fêtes fait des vidéos
d'apprentissage pour les échecs sur tu
as quand même et donc je dois lire avec
une voix agréable
je ne trouve pas sa gamme
non mais bon lire c'est pas c'est pas
évident c'est président c'est un peu
différent quand tu dis quelque chose de
poser alors pour mettre le skype à le
partage d'écran nous en sommes là nous
essayons de cadres et mais nous n'y
arrivons pas à tuer plein écran à à
skype a de nouveau changé sa manière de
cadres et alors c'est mieux
alors c'est plus beau mais c'est un
petit peu chiant oui c'est complètement
de la merde
bon c'est un souci technique que je
n'avais pas prévu non sinon ça va moi
les personnes dans le chat du trépas
personne n'a cru alors attends attends
donc une seconde parce que j'ai ce souci
de deux cadres at je fais n'importe quoi
je fais n'importe quoi mais j'y suis
presque
je fais moins n'importe quoi je fais pas
n'importe quoi du tout ah ouais je suis
pas mal je suis pas mal alors ce soir
fabien c'est le premier jeudi du mois
et qui dit premier jeudi du mois à 10
films x presque c'est pas loin at au
tournant le stream et qui dit-on
ravissent rim dit problèmes de connexion
comment ça va rires comment je vous en
main c'est la question que tout le monde
se pose alors il ya pas mal de
deux messages quand même à temps qu'est
ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
ce cas ci ça ok c'est bon j'ai réussi à
cadrer plus ou moins tout je peux encore
le partage d'écran alors je peux te
faire le partage d'écran je peux te
faire le partage d'écran mais là il y en
a plein sur l'écran de partout là mon
écran et en difficulté et du coup on se
marre des nouvelles alors pour ma propre
geste league ce week-end oui nous avons
des nous avons des nouvelles et une
valve sont assez bonnes puisque
normalement il y aura pro-chasse league
mais les nouvelles sont bonnes et
parfois dans la foi c'est à dire que là
maintenant pour commenter la prod chez
slick
il va falloir ça va être encore plus
compliqué d'un point de vue technique
avant ouais c'est à dire qu'on va faire
un truc que nous n'avions jamais jamais
fait et qui
il me semi inquiète parce qu'on l'a
jamais fait en fait on va devoir
commenter en mars
non on va devoir récupérer ce qu'ils
appellent un fichier rtmp très
intéressant c'est qu'à fenêtres ne
savons pas ce que c'est le configurer
pour que ça marche et je vais te dire
honnêtement
ça me fait se méfier en fait il son
point de presse
ouais je sens des problèmes techniques
pour un truc qui servira pas à grand
chose en fait
mais en fait du coup il ya un problème
maintenant c'est qu'en fait tu vois
avant ces événements elle est organisée
simplement par check point comme wayne
ont été plus ou moins tranquille chez ce
point commun ils s'en foutent mais
maintenant cesser alors après il ya eu
les partenariats avec avec les trucs de
master class donc c'était très bien
aussi
mais maintenant on est carrément des
partenariats avec avec twitch et donc
qui dit partenariat avec twitch ben dis
que ça doit être un peu plus clint au
niveau de l'image de groupes dauphin
tout ça exactement et donc et donc et
donc et donc et donc ça veut dire qu'il
va falloir que l'on bosse mieux qu'avant
tu vois comment on pouvait se permettre
de faire de la merde maintenant peu plus
d'1 go bon ça non mais en fait c'est
jusqu'à les tutoriels à regarder et tous
et que bon ben c'est pas ma passion quoi
il yad'autres tutoriel plumes en bas là
les tutoriels pour ajouter les fichiers
je crois que c'est rtmp 1 mais tu as des
trucs plus fun bon alors est ce qu'elle
est et du coup rtmp ce mot c'est à dire
en gros tu vois je peux te montrer toi
puisque tu es là en gros tu as des en
fichiers paramètres
je sais même pas où ces merveilles face
à faire qu en plus ou en moins on aura
des images des joueurs là en fait
honneur à lynette
il y aura un grain d'image sur un truc
quelque chose quoi fais nous rêver
en fait on aura les mais justement à
quatre lettres mais en fait on aura les
mêmes images que le truc officiel
les scores les machins les trucs mais
mais le truc c'est que je sais même pas
où c'est en fait j'ai regardé un
tutoriel pour voir comment faire mais tu
vois je sais je sais même pas où
naviguer sur le truc je sais même pas où
naviguer sur le truc donc il va falloir
que je regarde le tutoriel et ça m'a
l'air un peu galère honnêtement je sais
je sais plus tu as déjà bon gardien
non mais ça va bien se passer mais je
vais apprendre à le faire un de toute
façon tout le monde va le faire mais tu
n'y étais pas mais surtout toi ouais non
mais je sais pas mais bon tout le monde
tout le monde va y arriver donc on va y
arriver aussi mais c'est juste que
j'aime pas trop d des nouveaux trucs
j'ai pas les nouveaux trucs qui sont pas
testés avant fait jeu là tu voudrais des
matches amicaux pour mettre en place
tactique ta stratégie et est ok et faute
en coupe du monde que bon là là toute la
suisse à chiasso zone 3 5 2 machin lc
lycée sainte adapté quoi c'est ça en
fait j'aimerais bien avoir un tu as un
test en fait faire un test tout bêtement
d'une demi-heure pour arte c'est le truc
tranquille en offline tu vois et puis
après arriver c'est jusque là on va
arriver avec ce truc qu'on n'a jamais
fait on va arriver directement live
j'aime pas trop quoi je peux comprendre
je conçois mais tu es 10 et real-time
médias protocole voilà c'est ça ouais
donc fait c'est pas ça va être très
compliqué fondamentalement donc le toit
avait pas grand monde
voilà gillan qui demandent comment
s'inscrire au tournoi
bah écoute ce que j'ai fait en fait je
vais mettre un lien j'ai préparé une
marche à suivre alors attends je vais
t'envoyer ça alors c'était où cette
histoire là c'était bitstream c'était
events c'était s'était tournoi mensuel
comme ça je vais t'envoyer le lien en
fait j'ai essayé d'écrire
il est bien on est bien on est un con et
leucate aujourd'hui j'ai plus oui ça
qu'on est de 4 je sais pas qu'est ce que
c'est pour les deux amants peu importe
d'essayer de faire une marche à suivre
écrite pour que les gens puissent
trouver la méthode à plein de monde dans
le chatt pourquoi moi je les vois pas en
fait je comprends pas mais moi j'ai
plein de monde
en fait j'ai écrit et puis je ne vois
rien ah oui et d'enseignement du monde
pourquoi je m'oppose le chat j'ai du
monde il ya un cahier j'ai défié bus et
ambulance sur suez comme je vais le
poutre et qu'ils ne connaissent pas le
coup j'ai cinq je suis sûr alors attends
je vais faire un petit bull est dans le
coup j'ai trouvé un oeil au pouvoir mais
non c'est ce que mon lieu au march 11
ans mais j'étais surpris tu as vu quand
même les 90 personnes
live de la neige et des personnes tu
vois les gars nous étions 200 quand même
ouais voilà reina quoi ouais c'était
chaud c'était c'était chaud chaud patate
l'aréna sais pas s'il ya des gens qui
sont un chat maintenant qu'ils ont suivi
mais c'était épique à leur apprendra pas
spolié puisque il y aura le replay sur
sur youtube le suricate à elle et
suricates il était chaud ils étaient ils
étaient très très chaud les suricates
il ya des frenchies un peu qu'ils
jouaient à y ait beaucoup de frenchy je
veux plusieurs mecs du stream j'ai de la
communauté bitstream
il n'aimait que j'espère gagner pourtant
un strike non mais en plus ils me font
chier sur tous les points c'était c'est
insupportable les mecs en fait ils
n'abandonnez pas c'est à dire que je
vous régaler ce jeu c'est des trucs
cuisse rim pour le mec a une pièce
demandée relie les îles et dans le
tournoi quoi de ce soir le mec a une
pièce de moins bon bah
abandonne qua non je te joue jusqu'au
matt dégage ok je sais pas mais
l'objectif quand même de faim ok que les
mecs veuille me battre pourquoi pas tu
vois la rigueur mais mais que les mecs
toujours en bk je vais faire à 4 à 5 kg
mais que les mecs abandonne pas c'est
chiant québec veuille me bats qu'ils
essayent de faire leur maximum qui se
battent à fond auquel tu vois je suis
pas contre bassil déjà tu es contre mais
bon je préfère dire je veux pas leur
interdire mais que mais qui n'abandonne
pas bien sûr je pourrais te ment sans
gloire naquet safina lien mais le
caillou à suite en âge fit d'ailleurs
quel génie ce mec je suis pas super pas
son passeport russe sur une finale comme
ça golog quoi bah ouais dégage
après tu es maître fide quoi du coup je
m'accroche je suis quand même pas ton
pions dégage narval il était
complètement été beaucoup mieux pour lui
dans cette finale voilà tu peux jamais
perdre ainsi enfin la preuve que si quoi
tu veux qu'ils ouvrent le passage aux
fous tu te trompe l'oeil et ensuite tu
en nous écrit tepic l'aréna m'habitue à
non mais c'est insupportable et c'est
pas le seul à mme nouara moeller a fait
1 mais après ils se sont fait chambrer
sur le discorde les mecs sylvaine place
m.ban donne quoi non mais là c'est pas
une arena tu fais ce que tu veux oui bon
c'est pas très intéressant mais en à
force de ne pas abandonner face c'est
pas un mec du stream c'est un bulgare il
a failli m'arnaquer pas tout d'un coup
il fait un sacrifice de dames bon bah il
n'avait pas compris lui-même mais en
fait ce sacrifice de dames est très bon
et tout d'un coup il ya des menaces de
maths et où j'ai fait une ferme à thé
c'était horrible pas c'était joli en
fait mais j'étais dégoûté je suis un peu
n'importe quoi en fait
complètement la merde mais a du coup
elle j'étais énervé que les mecs du
stream avant de l'appareil
non mais c'est pas on se connaît en plus
et je perds ya de l'argent en jeu phare
abandonné quoi tu fais ce russe cov
respecte ton rap aux paroles de la pièce
avec ses pas envie de me fatiguer je
t'envoie le pion dessus des gages moi je
suis très pragmatique la grille un
objectif d'envoyer le pion dessus écoute
c'est comme non mais c'est tellement
simple c'était même difficile de se
concentrer
ça car le tournant à 20h30 alors
attention combien jean inscrit que 13
personnes là qu'est ce qui se passe là
premier prix si peu de gens se tournent
je débats d'actu il ya toujours du monde
bon comme ont pu le monde on en commet
s'inscrire à temps je vais renvoyer le
lien j'ai fait un petit tutoriel vous
l'envoyez de ce qu'on a un petit copier
coller ouais copier coller j'ai un petit
tutoriel non le nouveau site avancent
bien non le site
ouais ouais ouais il ya quasiment film
n'est du goût est souvenu des demandes
pour le stage
non pas du tout dormi non pas du tout
mais aussi tu es fini quasiment dos des
gens me disent mis les boules palets
très bien enfin moi aussi j'aime bien
enfin par rapport à ce que je peux faire
c'est le top
quelle fight the guardian c'est même
mieux que pas mal de sites le proje
pensons mais c'est un site pro quelque
part oui bien sûr il ya des mecs et 4
piles sait combien programmées ainsi des
kits a qui te font moins bien oui mais
bon enfin son père je sais comment pour
commenter des tours à des chats qui te
font de la merde tu vois photo co j'ai
envie de te dire c'est un peu partout
c'est un peu la même chose dans tous les
domaines
bon écoute moi ce que je vais faire
c'est que j'ai remplacé mes pièces
fabien cimade et double les pions
pourquoi pas je vais mettre le pion f4
tueur par l'ena les sauveurs ah ouais
les sommets
à donges est une graminée à me faire
tomber là je crois que le rapport au
matériel fou qu'on cavaliers le mec il
aime pas à lloret je veux le faire moi
du coup je pense d'égaler le faire lui
mais je vous prends des cinq échecs fait
attention
précisons à l'unss ces échecs lui en
premier bon bah écoute 1
nul
j'ai envie de te dire news
en l'écoutant
à
aïe aïe aïe c'est qu'on peut aller en
mal de mecs me fait tomber il ne s'est
pas joué et tout ou pas notre gueule
quoi bah ouais mec ne sait pas jouer il
oblige à nous faire tomber alors attends
le vrai le vrai hein
il reste treize minutes avec et qu'ils
se calment il est en fait manqué 20h18
oui mais il reste 13 8 pour s'inscrire
on à l'otan a les yeux sinon refait rue
où se trouve le lien pour une
inscription du coup demande fils-aime
maroc et mais le lien jeu l'enjeu l'a
envoyé il faut pas exagérer les mecs ya
le tutoriel je crois dans le chatt
quelque part m sinon bon je peux vous
fait un petit tutoriel vocal quoi vous
allez sur photoshop.com se connecter aux
autres membres du groupe bitstream bon
ça c'est la base et qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire après tu vas dans jouée en direct
tournoi et quand tu es dans ce tournoi
c'est un anglais et à le tourner blue
stream s'appelle lavrard et là c'est ça
ouais la vraie à reinach et mais tu fais
participer ou un truc comme ça
voilà c'est vraiment différent de
l'aréna d'hyères en fait y est et a
fortiori à fos vaporeux organisée par
mon nom mais j'étais content du tout en
haut de l'aréna hier je me suis bien
amusé j'aime bien en fait c'est
probablement mon format de tournoi
préféré en fait les arénas mais en fait
non mais j'aime bien le fait que tu
attendes pas en fait pour jouer ouais
donc je comprends mais bon après c'est
ok bah c'est pas le format atx est
normal ouais mais je préfère justement
non mais ça dénature que je peux enfin
je n'ai pas les questions à branler de
gagner en 3 coups en 500 ce qui compte
c'est gagner aux échecs c'est ce qui
compte c'est comme si c'est comme si au
foot c'est je sais pas quoi c'est comme
si au foot
bon si tu marques un but dans les dix
premières minutes tu martic point quoi
bonus + 3 points de la victoire mais au
basket à bien les paniers à 2 points et
à trois points aux normands ou comme
c'est pas parce que tu marques
dix secondes de jeu que que tu as un
bonus ou parce que tu marques 20 points
dans les dix premières minutes je sais
pas quoi tu vois pas je sais c'est pas
le principe de budget vite quoi c'est
vrai mais c'est fun et c'est marrant
quoi permet d'envoyer du lourd de fer
doit pas juste ça détend sade est en
fait j'ai rien contre les échecs sur
internet en général mais quand ils
dénaturent le jeu se bat c'est un autre
jeu en fait ouais ouais ça mais ces
échecs ce nom mais ses fans pour pour
stream et étouffe
c'est plus fun quand tu stream pas moi
non mais tu attends pas seul au point de
telles puces des sept jours deux idiots
qui ont une partie de 150 coups bas
c'est sa finale complètement nul qui
vont tourner en rond c'est super chiant
quand tu regardes eux s'arrêtent ou
tamponnais hockey chez moi j'ai une
solution qui fait des parties en chaos
puis c'est fini
ouais mais là du coup il multiplie quoi
ils te font ekahau est et à rennes et à
rennes un bon ben ok alors versements
mais a jugé moins paquet d'affaires ce
format dans les échecs money va tourner
là ce serait la fouly encore sur
internet pourquoi traverser un peu dans
l'esprit gaming et où tu as etc ou le
sol ça te permet de ces pour stream et
c'est bien on va dire que vu que c'est
un tour à pour l'estrie marron plus on
va dire que c'est ils ont trouvé un bon
format pour les gens qui stream parce
que du coup tu tu enchaînes les parties
tu fais de la merde tu joues un cocon
douillet mecque de la communauté aussi
par une ligue 2 mais que la communauté
bitstream s'est inscrit au tournoi en
fait qui jouait le truc et du cou et du
coup les gars jouent pour jouer non
seestream si en fait mais bon font-ils
encore parce que la communauté s'il te
font concurrence
ouais nan mais il faudrait en fait à la
limite pourquoi pas tu vois mes mais du
coup c'est très très sympa ce que tu
rejoues sont des mecs de la communauté
et tous faim
j'aime bien le truc en fait
non mais c'est toi qui me plaît en fait
ouais je suis mal quand même un pion une
preuve hôtel tout l'or du monde
après mise à part ma pièce j'ai pas
grand chose donc ça c'est plutôt cool ce
que je vais me paraît que lecavalier
bouffer un pion qu'est messi mérite mon
cavalier en vie fut heureux parce que
j'ai plus de temps et massages des
bougies c'est de lui nuire et s'est
déplacé une fourchette ou un truc un
truc c'est que j'ai plus de temps
pourtant je l'avais réussi à l'arnaqué
contre eux j'ai bien l'arnaqué du canon
ouais bon retour ok j'ai voulu sac et le
truc ce que j'ai l'impression que six
pouces et son pion tu vois non mais hier
c'est pareil puisque amr en fait
enfin chacun a sa stratégie en fait dans
l'arena moi mon amour ma stratégie dans
l'aréna c'est de jouer que de la mer
mais d'essayer de gagner très vite en
fait pourquoi je vais dénature le jeu à
fond en fait je joue que des coups de
merde et j'essaye d'arnaqueurs maximum
et amr lui sa stratégie c'est de tout
gagner mais du coup tu vois chaque
stratégie à son as et plus et c'est
moins en fait moi j'ai plus de déchets
ou là on a perdu le skype est ce que
j'ai perdu internet ou pas non on va
essayer de rappeler ça va être chaud du
coup de gagner la partie fait pas ce qui
se passe c'est la connexion de fable qui
a dû qui a dû lâcher
donc j'étais en train de dire dames 8
peut être un coup de fouet
je sentais qu'il allait le voir new york
deux jours à une déconnexion dur à
comprendre
mais du coup on partagera des crampes
pression du plus à un peu mis dans la
merde pas mal de temps mais bon tant pis
c'est le jeu ouais donc je disais en
fait hammer lui il essaye de tout gagner
par exemple ok mais il est plus fort
donc il a raison mais du coup moi j'ai
une autre stratégie qui concrètement l
inverse de la sienne en fait donné vite
gagner vite une peur vix ouverte dans
mes prières vite way plus pour gagner
plus mais du coup en début de tournoi ça
payait pas trop parce que j'ai perdu
quelques parties importantes mais après
le truc c'est quand j'ai commencé ma
remonte à la ba en fait j'ai gagné plein
de partir rapidement parce que je fasse
je joue des trucs pour essayer de gagner
très vite en fait des recours aux aidés
been des attaques de matala combat tu
vois et puis même si une position avec
une pièce de plus je sais pas de la
mener tranquillement en finale tu vois
enfin je m'en fout en fait je continue à
sacrifier mais du coup c'est fun quand
tu stream parce que monta les mecs et
toutes majeures
hugo boss non mais c'est très drôle en
quoi tu fais que de la merde
objectivement c'est de la merde et oui
mais en fait c'est cool ce que chacun a
faim tu vois c'est un tout comme à la
formule à l'arrêt au stand
chacun sa stratégie mais en fait il n'a
pas eu de bol hammers basse qui s'est
fait défoncer par en scène et du coup
lui dans sa stratégie voiture moi je les
contrats marc en quatorze coups j'étais
moins bien j'ai tenté un type oh j'ai
perdu je m'en fous tu vas pas l'arnaqué
pas passée je suis passé à autre chose
quoi fâcher n'est partie du coût a marre
il m'a battu mais le problème c'est que
marine est non car la cuvée tu vas aller
tu vas les mauvais mais moins vite que
moi que ça attention
mais mais du coup voilà bon tout ça pour
dire que c'est marrant comme format et
que c'est bien parce que ça a permis de
jouer moi aussi contre des mecs du
discorde
donc c'était sympa matière une
fourchette mais je suis encore chaud de
l'aréna d'hier quand même hein tu sens
en terme de level en un repère du fab
bon quand bien même refermer son script
on l'a on le repère perdido fabián
écouter on va envoyer le pion h
bah écoute et or on va les enfermer sont
floues on va le manger et on va essayer
de tenir même si ça fait un peu peur
je crois pas qu'on puisse tenir sa yo yo
yo des pages très tard ce passage aucune
idée pourquoi alors journée marché hyper
bien c'est des petites scories qua non
mais j'ai eu ça le hier après-midi en
fait bizarrement ça a fait pareil en
fait ça des connections internet je sais
pas pourquoi ces petites scories dans la
connexion était content de la qualif
deux de nos amis fin de la qualif du
match de nos amis de liverpool
j'ai regardé ce match irait alors je
suis content fatma mais oui vahid en
juge plutôt aller plutôt pour liverpool
pour la pour l'histoire les supporteurs
et les compagnies quoi réviser en fait
hier les aider c'était un peu les frères
du psg commence à qui manchester city
ouais enfin bon ils ont déjà vu un type
dans les années 60 quand même un faux
pas un club né de la dernière pluie quoi
ah ouais mais dans les prisons il ya un
autre truc important en fait aussi à
dire une grosse différence enter deux
clubs s'excite hisser le club populaire
en fait de manchester à la base c'est le
petit club qui a toujours été aimé par
tu vois c'était un club de battants quoi
bon donc ok c'est quand même deux choses
très différentes mais ok après
concrètement maintenant oui deux clubs
très riche mais bon c'est pas le
problème est bon pour toi sans je suis
perso plus
juste d'accord avec ça en anglais
leicester city en angleterre chauffe
plus de mérite à gagne plus en
angleterre quand tu se coltine
manchester united tottenham arsenal
liverpool chelsea et que tu as tout ça
en face que tokyo en france juste tu
t'assures 4kids nationaux chaque année
quoi dubois qui n'en soit que tu comptes
la coupe des machins en tant que titre a
bondi nous dise dans les jambes oui
c'est par un titre ça n'en ont pas
vraiment mais c'est une coupe dans ses
vitrines quoi fin ouais ouais ouais mais
après et d'un autre côté je sais même
pas pourquoi ils jouissent commencé
champion de france contre vainqueur de
la coupe de france donc il n'avait pas
ou pas ces fatwas
enfin tu devrais faire paris contre par
idéal ce serait plus chaud de sortie
soit quoi mais en fait je me demande si
paris a contre paris b aurait pas plus
de jeu au pic en quoi en fait su mêler
aux femmes si tu prends pas ça ce joueur
insu fait le meilleur onze on se
retranche choses franchement je pense
que l'équipe b de paris est plus forte
que l'équipe de marseille en fait pas
j'en suis méninges sûrement c'est
l'équipe b s'est tu mettras peau cage
tue mais menez à droite tu mets tu mets
berisha gauche tu mets qui pembe
défenseur central bon avec un autre mec
je sais pas que tu veux non mieux tu
dois avoir motta le celso pastore ouais
c'est pas mal actionnaires
time cook août di maria tension qui
passe en sept titulaires normalement
mais ton équipe normale n'est pas
ségolène a une bonne équipe en fait
équipé de harry peut-être champion de
france dans une bonne année qua non mais
je pense que dans une année normale qui
est champion de france a expliqué m
oui mais j'ai ressenti que de parler des
champions mais je veux dire ok mais même
peut-être axe équipe je veux finir
devant l'autre quoi
mais que dire que le champion reste
champion quoi je suis champion berra
temps qu'ils ont su en frétillant fait
on va suivre matin faire parce que
j'espère qu'il va pas de set dub est ce
que c'est un peu parce que celle de
bastia il m'a fait un sale coup c'est à
dire bah il a failli me battre mais s'il
a juste famille c'est grave
tu as osé quoi il a osé c'est une
batterie en plus l'autre cette manie que
ça le faisait marrer et après il m'a
fait un autre sale coup c'est que quand
j'ai une tour de plus il m'a fait jouer
jusqu'au match pour me faire chier ça
c'est le plus gros seul coup sinon que
ce que je veux dire mais bon je te
rassure il a perdu enfin même si je me
doute j'en parlerai pas ici j'en
parlerai non mais jaillissent effet mat
et à l'ancienne madmad de l'escalier
facture haye les choses les choses bien
comme il faut ben mince matin ferme et
fr en pls ewen vont revenir sinon à
liverpool 6/3
bah grands battus trop de liverpool
niveau niveau motivation tout ça les
vertus qu'ils ont montré c'était beau
quoi et liverpool liverpool c'est un
truc que j'arrive pas à comprendre en
fait mais
on dit les grands joueurs dans les
grands matches c'est souvent vrai mais
je rajouterais les grands clubs dans les
grands matches en fait ce club en fait
non mais c'est étrange comme truc fable
quand même parce que city sont leaders
du championnat il joue bien la prendre
c'est une erreur de matha faire un tu
dois jamais changé d'âme
ok et quand bien même cavalier e 5 c'est
de la merde quoi tu dois tenter enfin
sinon tu abandonnes à échanger lammens
position enfin tu ne peux pas quoi mais
vrai j'y vais c'est marrant fait ce truc
des grands clubs basques hommes la
jugent bon look et son prix mais en
général oui ils sont là bas alors que
des faisait paniquer qui faisait rêver
mais qui s'accroche
non mais c'est bizarre mais tu vois
l'état ait de vraies institutions tu as
un poids tu as un truc de l'histoire
tels le public tu te sens manquez pas le
maillot représente quelque chose que je
sais pas en fait c'est marrant surtout
rêve de il peut peut-être tentés fous
ces cinq avec un truc tu peux pas à
prendre le cavalier parce que tu as kf3
de fouine battu peu oui mais génère par
la queue bizarrement il s'est un peu mis
le feu tout seul ouais c'est dommage
qu'ils n'aient pas commencé par pousser
5 à mathay faire s'arrêter plus piégeurs
je pense donc quand bien même il y
aurait autour d'eux et tout mais géré
par là ça a été plus une en de même se
prendre la fourchette laissez-passer g
je sais mais vu tout ce que jarnac et
hier en fait tu vois je guette à une
pièce de moins tu commences à remonter
temps récupère une qui aurait fait un
verrier à loches pour en finir avec lui
voir coup le machin pour le coup juste
ce n'est pas encore fini non maintenant
je viens 3 0 c'est beaucoup mais il peut
se prendre le retour n'ont en revanche
pour la nouvelle danse à ce volume
malheureusement victime dont la juge
était dégoûté enfin j'ai pas vu mais
j'ai vu que la première mi temps mais
j'ai de suite compris par le problème
c'est quand tu te prends un but après
deux minutes de jeu un but évitable
complètement parce que tu laisse
déborder facile les mecs à droite est le
parrain gauche tu ronaldo qui reprend
évidemment make-up à 30 est ce un appui
ils ont raté pas mal d'occasions
mi-temps et puis bon il y avait penalty
sur il ya eu une faute sur 10 voilà où
il apprit carton jaune pour simulation
et bp 90
non mais a fait mouche pas non mais oui
mais il touche le joueur dans la surface
il fait un croche patte dans la surface
quand même failli mais son pied
le son pied touche le pied il n'a pas
touché le ballon il ya penalty non mais
tu peux te trompes effacé passe pas
scandaleux quoi après de disons que
mettre un carton aux mecs paraissent pas
c'est quand même ce qu'on a vue de
pacifier penalty quand un penalty quand
même nom mais des biens dits très
flamande
la nar dans les trucs qu'il a raté il y
avait atteint 5,1 petits trucs à
connaître pour les gens vous faites h5
là est en fait le pion peut pas prendre
parce que sinon les deux cavaliers qui
tombe je réussis ça marche pas parce que
vous pourrez tourcoing f6 mais h5
ça permet de dévier le truc savard est
de sauver bon ben du coup matt affaire
qui m'a déçu il apparaît bien
représentés bajeux se propose d'aller
voir qui peut-être fujiwara gostai arrêt
funérailles il a perdu deux dames tête
amine tv du coup contre contrario are
you qui est que sébastien joie qu'on a
pu voir dans l'estrie mais qui veut
essayer de gagner tournoi j'imagine boli
grand favori non vraiment il va jouer
contre son pote l'autre seule balle
autre salle il est dangereux il a failli
comme celui d'hier
après j'ai battu les deux hier dans le
tour 1 les deux scènes j'ai battu les
deux seb
j'ai fait 2 sur 2 contre les sabres
cette de beast et cette joie not the
boss tout seul échec pendant dix jours
il ya le ya le gros title tuesday ouais
mais fait ça m'impressionne djamel mois
des jeux sur internet je deviens fou non
plus les 5000 c'est gros comme enfin
5000 en mai
au premier vingt ans tout en prix mais
il va peut-être y avoir de 20 milles au
près non mais mène 2000 au premier c'est
beaucoup pour un truc qui dure deux
heures non bien sûr
des fois je vous aurai une semaine ne
viennent pas ça au premier donc
évidemment c'est beaucoup mais j'espère
sera encore là mais je pense qu'il y
aura un minimum n'a qu'à une réelle
enfin peut-être
outre karl scène est-ce que ça domine
preuves mettant kung fu et tu peux
tenter ta chance à qui sait ou tout
autre je ferais je sais pas l'armée de
façon de t'en fiches super deux parties
tu t'arrêtes pas mais tu peux gagner un
toit mouline enfin il y en a qu à
karlsson bel et bien fait moins une fois
pourquoi pas toi moi non je crois pas je
vais pas je pense que depuis que j'ai
fais humaine que tout le monde peut
faire en fait et carlucet nyakam ce qui
va avec games qui ça va c'est jouable
mais carlson non sur une partie je fais
une robe quoi que tu fasses non mais ok
mais mieux qu'einstein vais donc état
caruana enfin octane à cas où je sais
pas qui feint auquel on sait trop quoi
christa qu'un mec qui fait des most
people la rigueur ce coffret métal
système d'appariement d'izard sur une
chaise comme où tu peux éviter carrément
tout le monde très bizarrement modem
j'ai put jamais personne wata plage
suite entré site à site à site à 3 sur 4
tu récites à 3 sur 5 hectares est bon
parce que j'ai rien à personne pas quel
jour sommes au courant assez mardi me et
pourquoi pas en photo la voix mais avec
des champions comme c'est sympa quoi
city liverpool quoi mardi nice et sa
city liverpool annoncé mardi
celui-là karim c'est mardi 7 alors des
17 ya peut-être absolument rien mais
rien n'y fait avec soyez personnes
furieuses c'est trop tard pour rejoindre
ben oui ce retard pour rejoindre sec
suprématie tous les tournois faut
toujours être à leur attention les
tontons
bon ben victoire belle victoire des
blancs je me demande en fait ce qui
s'était passé
allez on va voir razoux contre celle qui
s'échauffe avait peut-être une surprise
dans cette partie celle qui savait que
les noirs qui est quand même pas mal
hein non monsieur il ya 500 points lot
de moi mais non mais j'ai encore frisé
c'est du trois coups ce que cette
connexion que ayvaz non ça va il tient
la pièce c'est le temps des six c'est
chaud je pense qu'il va perdre autant ce
qu'ils croient ou jetons fou comme vous
aussi ce jeu il va tomber sa santé qu'il
est en panique mais c'est pas évident de
preview et un après bon faut aussi
c'était surtout épaules oui mais mon
truc c'est que toi tu le vois mes
salut casse couilles en 2001 mais
qu'elle a truck a pas oubliés pour city
jô que sa part donc ok déjà un
championnat à city a battu bochum 5 0
skyrock est déjà si l'on fait une fois
c'est faisable et auquel juste ils
peuvent très bien jouer que certains un
grand match tu prêches et pas salakis à
retiers blessés ce qui s'est passé
pendant une semaine
parfois on a 1 jusqu'au panneau je crois
que la théorie la cfu des cartes et
chèques et des cinq noms ouais
après il faut connaître
n'as tu pas prendre 4 je connais pas
trop elles prennent quand tu prends une
claque reçue à toi reprendre des machins
il faut croire que ça tu peux arriver
moi c'est juste faire des cinq manon oui
ça vous excusez pas pour le sens entrant
gens comme ça prend le 5e tour même des
massifs et le 5 avec les blancs il est
très bien entouré rock ok puis que
également fermé vraiment important de
lutter pour le centre des 5
ok on a 2 millions de francs et à la
bonne structure
ok je crois que c'est là dessus que je
fais des nuls à la con tu donnes des
trois racailles à 5 damas cats qui sait
si ça ne m'a troublé trois mois qui est
petit niel c'est mieux de chars nul que
de se prendre au 5 mai on l'attend quand
la chance de faire des tris du coup
comme les blancs chrétiens
est ce qu'ils écoutent le stream ou
parent ne sais pas il doit bien fait
quoi non mais c'est sûr que faire des
petites nul c'est bien enfin moi je
reste pour moi je savais faire que des
nuls dames et trois qui est à 5 damas
quatre new look est fou bonne partie
nous n'avons pas fait d'erreur tu es
l'analyse alors 10 001 précision 0 gaffe
zéro faute
100% de bon coussin bon sens opérateurs
je peux pas laisser ces bébés c'était
enfin confondre avec la pca non non mais
ça ça va être un peu mieux pour les
noirs non c'est juste égal toujours du
mal à évaluer ce truc là bas c'est
peut-être eagle bon gameplay cinq fois
qu'on s'est tenue pour la force la même
cavalier b61 peut-être fait grève et 6
mai à skis et prend des quatre aussi et
tu m'as ce cavalier à 5 presse que tu
prends tout en ces cas tu pourra prendre
en f3 après tu fais qu'un v6 je fais
cavalia à 5 et échanges tout en
s'écartant n'as rien tu paieras là tu
veux pas tolérés tu dois faire de nous
des trois un coup je sais pas n'importe
quoi
il fait cavalier reste inquiet qu'on a
un truc mais là tu des changes ces
quatre ayant fait les blancs est le truc
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas d'activité de
pièces qui doivent avoir pour compenser
leurs pieds désolé pour ce soit à
changer les pièces mineurs qui est des
cinq est bien sympathique alliant de 5,5
après si je joue bien je pense si tu
peux tu peux tenir pas du lac et bien
pénible parata sont ok juste tout le
temps aux échecs on a un stade où on a
compris que quasiment aucune pollution
était gagnante
non mais ça doit pouvoir faire genre
cavaliers 5 et f3 revenir avec la dame
mais les tours en face c'est pénible
marche peuvent te prendre l'espace avel
da te mettes détour ni de faire des vins
et autres divas défendre du chien non
c'est sûr mais en fait ça hallucinant
maintenant tout ce que tu arrives à
défendre grâce à leur nid bon on peut
vraiment voir des fantômes mais en fait
c'est pas finalement c'est pas ça qu'il
faut se demander ce qu'est ce que ça
donne en pratique en pratique ouais mais
en pratique mais encore que j'ai même vu
des mecs qu'ils ont défendu des trucs
contre carl scène avec des purs isolé
comme ça en blindant un mondial étonnant
c'est que je suis désolé par la finale
la fameuse flore montre capable en cas
qui est nul ça dépasse un peu nous truc
normal quoi
keith sherin et ouais ok c'est la
fameuse finale où les noirs ont pu
isoler en d5 et ils ont tout et on le
schiste comme ça ils ont le roi qui sera
un drame pions brandon roy des 6 et les
blancs juste ils ont à bgh ou bien ils
ont un cavalier en d4 et le roi mais en
fait je suis pas ta le pion faible faire
cavaler contre un flou mais sa série oui
mais ça mais ok c'est juste ok si même
ça saigne déjà quasiment sans temps
maintenant que nous courant
finalement tu peux dire beaucoup de
pression mais je sais pas si tu rajoutes
détour c'est quand même nul ou pas non
je pense le tour c'est quelque chose
on ne sait pas en fait personne ne s'est
en fait plateau savoir la nuit c'est
tous à chaque main mais je pense que kim
tour déjà tu as des chances de gagner
blanc mais ça dépend quel tour à quel
moment car si les blondes jalran des
deux équipes prennent les quatre entrées
ok ça qu'on s'être de bons espoirs si
c'est les tours au début où certaines
tournées en europe courant s'est vite
alors on vient en fait n'en fait rien
quoi non mais je sais pas ce que mature
dit vlad sait que pour gagner contre le
pion isolé faut garder les dames
ok peut-être les tours aussi non mais
les dames et les souris mais il m'a dit
déjà si tu as vu les dames c'est chiant
le mieux c'est garder deux tours dame
est fou de la bonne couleur de la
couleur du pion
c'est lui mais un manager qui attaquent
l'option d'un meilleur matériel ces
dames de tours est fou qui attaquent
l'option c'est un peu là parce bobic
ouais celle qu'on avait fait ou tu
pousses tri pion par les hongrois
l'avait fait pour la master class des
carcasses qui est aussi un peu comme ça
mais en fait c'est les parties modèle
pour gagner ça et c'est le meilleur
matériel en fait le meilleur rapport à
matériels motorisés ont misé l'écran ne
s'affiche pas mais si l'écran est
affiché
on a un souci avec ça attendu bien
recadrer mais oui donc les plus isolées
c'est pas toujours évident on a reperdu
fabien je sais pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui mais j'ai eu le même
problème comme je disais hier après midi
chez moi avec site internet qui partait
tout le temps alors là est ce qui peut
passer la tour sur la 7e ou pas investi
chez eux il reste 20 secondes vrai
messie 3 + 2 c'est dommage qu'il ait
reculé saddam en fait parce que il avait
à me dire placé eelv a pu mettre la tour
en d1 et la tour en le set peut-être et
c'est un peu dommage qu'il ait reculé
saddam verbe et 3 surtout que le roi
toute façon pas très bien placé
ok dam d'un système c3 manqué il va
taper le plan c 6 mais il s'est un peu
affaibli aussi il s'est un peu affaibli
les cases de tours du rangement g3
peut-être qu'ils auraient dû préférer h3
avoir alors qu'ils doublent ou larroy f1
on sent qu'ils paniquent faire attention
où la foudre en f3 je pense est une
grosse erreur c'est une très grosse
erreur faut prendre froid les gens parce
qu'en fait il pas y gagne même pas de
pions et en fait il perd tout le
bénéfice de ces cases blanches faible
larroy g2 aussi grosse erreur évidemment
il fallait jouer b4 au moins tout était
protégé et maintenant la torah deux très
bien placé la torah 6 pas très bien je
pense à quesnoy faut tenter de faire h
6-3 6-7 et ramener cette tour quelque
part peut-être tours fc est en premier
et histoire de couvrir la septième à
tour ces deux j'aime pas sur ces gemmes
pas parce que cette tour était très bien
placé derrière le pion à leurs est fier
qu'on va filer vers la prochaine partie
alors là on va les voir beats heures
contre loulo buteur qui a battu jours
allez on va les voir aller tan sayah
voilà qui va gagner et tours de plus
vraiment vraiment plus de tours s'est
pas produit joue bernard pouchecot à
marans cette finale finale avec le pion
le carré des joueurs il a classé m 1000
lots alors est ce qui va réussir à
trouver le plan pour ramener leur a
versé 5 encaissés le pion il a un beau
une belle barrière de corail avec son
cavalier et son pion c'est plutôt bien
si en train de faire à héron à ses 5
c'est très très bien joué et ça joue pas
mal à 1000 063 ses seins qui protège la
attention de tafer qu'il prend un f4
très bien joué c'est pas piéger qu'elle
prend ces sept on va revenir avec le
cavalier show pétillant et ont renvoyé
le pion à ou envoyer deux pions la
direccte et accueille des cinq cantons
car il prend un f4 tu enlève ton
cavaliers tu pousses le plus bref s'il
vient vers le plus bref tu pousses le
pion à aller tonton allez on arrête le
kava l'on pousse
ça joue pas mal et on pousse on pousse
on pousse allez on envoie le plus bref
on s'en fiche du cavale bon
elle aimerait continuer
c'est gagné
donc il reste encore une partie rockets
le joueur arrivant avec les blancs sa
fille par un pacte j'ai pas vu si ça
finit par un pad j'ai pas lu j'ai pas le
classement du tournoi par contre tiré
quand je fais commenter sa partie mahé
coup de pyro pourquoi pas à la roue et
pierrot
tu met un petit roeulx fraîche pour
réussir à commenter la partie suivante
alors il est où pierrot pierrot un gosse
mon combat mon poteau ou frangins 28 me
tient chaud
pierrot maria zoom qui nous dit qu'il
est nouveau ici dit bonjour bonjour zoom
sais pas comment tu as fait pour faire
le truc tu es nouveau ici alors qu'est
ce qui se passe est parti de pied on va
revenir des quatre des cinq c4 sac à
franges ou g4 alors là ça aurait très
envie de faire cavalier 5 mon pierrot tu
attaques le fou après que mes états
d'âme en b3 tu tapes sur bessette ces
cinq sur bessette la fin tu as dame là
tu tapes ici ici qui avait lieu cinq
étapes ici donc je me serais senti bien
se qualifier 3 priest a repris 2 e
j'aurais plutôt repris 2 g dans cette
position pour essayer de faire une
grosse masse centrale et pousser les
pions de quatre noms mais je comprends
que tu es repris 2 e et que tu retombes
d'un espèce de trompe au ski avec un
temps de plus par an les noirs et du
essaie de privilégier un frein xj6 fou
g7
ok il ne l'a pas fait et il te fait
c'est sain car j'aurais pensé avec les
noirs qui est affair prise prise est
toujours un truc avec ses 6 pour te
laisser le pion isolé au centre puisque
ton pions avaient été déviés vers eux et
peut-être amené le cavalier vers des
cinq écoutes mon pierrot et vous
souhaiter à rf et ça je pense que c'est
déjà assez bien joué après faux calcul
de ce qui se passe sur cd il fallait
regarder je sais pas mais c'est dé
saturer attaque et on cavaliers bon mais
à la rigueur pas aux cas à voir mais
peut-être j'aurais pris dans l'autre
sens prise prises et du coup tu as
peut-être reprendre en d5 l'autre
reprend tu fais fouet 4 et albion
bessette qui restent en ligne de mire
et si l'autre reprend du pied eux
peut-être vrai mais là tu vas jouer
contre un pion isolé qui va pas vraiment
être enfin il va être isolé mais il va
être isolé passer tous à cause du fait
que ton pions soit là est plus là en
fait c'est peut être toi tu serais très
bien mon pierrot
à du coup tu veux être bouffé bouffer et
mettre le fou ou trois comme ça le mec
te bouffe tu peux rbo fait de f
peut-être avoir pas sur vous tous d'être
bouffé bouffer d'un bébé 3 tu vas un peu
jouer de l'autre côté l'auto fait dame
b6 et chaumont à fait fou et 3 mais j'ai
peur que pierrot nous écoute en fait
mais peut-être trucs plus malins à faire
j'en sais rien pierrot presque pierrot
peut tenter dams et de l'idée j'attaque
le fooding c'est fou prend 1,3 je lui
claque un petit fou prend h7 férois h 8
puis on prend 3 mais peut-être ici c'est
je me fais enfermer le fou attendait ce
que vous m'avez suivi donc la double
attaque faut prendre trois fous prend
hc3 chouity à le fou qui reste sur trois
je dois leur bouffer et g6 et mon fonds
acheter at il fait la gueule ça m'a
refroidi on va reprendre fabio est ce
qu'on a eu des surprises aux deux
tournois
yao fabas on a une grosse game là on a
une game très intéressante
bon en fait je prends pas ce qui se
passe mal à l'aise box qui n'est pas
régi saute à gré plutôt repris ma mon
pierrot temps je en train de parler à
bien je marche un romain je ne marche
plus tessier pas si pire aurait pas dû
repousser du pion là pour essayer de
jouer le pion isolé on peut toujours
[Musique]
apprécié pas est ce que le pion en e3
aurait été aussi un peu arriérés avoir
notre jour courant propos là notre
pierrot nationale est-ce que tu avais
peut-être tentés du f4 f5 du coup du
coup il un bélier pas pour essayer d'un
petit peu hein
l'éboulement qui les rend pierrot mais
là peut-être cavaliers ces six tours
prend des 5 et b4 tu vois n'est
peut-être un petit cahier c6 la piété
chien tu peux pas payer 4 m et mon amant
dont beaucoup quoi belle maison c'est
pierrot quoi et c'est un adversaire qui
voit des trucs celle qui se bat celle
qui ce cas font t'es obligé de rentrer
enfin à la maison
tu vas te faire bouffer f4 ou war 3 mais
bon tu vas te faire bouffer f4 celle qui
ce qui est chaud patate
celle qui ce qui fait mal à pierrot fab
quelques tours j'ai 5
ouais mais dampha f4 attention voire
attention fabien surtout reprend des 5es
et b4 mon seul keroppi rocchi pied
rocchi qui souffrent le martyre mais
c'est pas grave on recule et mon boss
des sacrifices mais on est très contents
agissent très affaiblissant les pierrots
tour g3 tempo vous projet il perd direct
pierrot a fait boum
né à pierrot mme marois qui aurait
complètement raide
pire on va perdre pied on va mourir dans
cette partie si pire vous pouvez jouer
dame afsset en utilisant une carte qui
te permet de sauter au dessus de ton fou
pierrot serait très bien la pierre qui
reculent guy roux qui va être acculé
dans son camp dans ses 16 mètres seconde
ces 22 mai dans ses 22 mètres et même de
mettre ta raison faut qu'il passe le
ballon à lionel beauxis pour dégager
notre pierrot nationale
si le passe à trin duc à mon avis la
touche va finir en ballons noirs
tu ne sais pas le mec il est capable de
te faire d'un coup de pied tellement
davis et que laval repart dans son camp
à les tours à huit salles qui sont
conteste la colonne et une tour de plus
pierrot qui propose de jouer dame f5
dans sa propre parti pour mettre la
pression
il est chaud la pression sera fait très
très attention de permettre aux la
pression parce que tu vas te faire
matériaux sains
il va se faire prendre et d'un me 5 la
pression va être sur son fourrage 5 à
celle qui ce qu'ils voient tous tempo
celle qui se cache au fab à l'aisselle
kiss tour 8
lacombe 90 ans 5-6 je sais plus personne
ne sait francis bon sens quand même bon
pour pour ce disque avec caïd écartée
celle qui ça mon avis qui peut signer la
feuille
bravo pierrot bien jeu quand même mais
tu t'es fait défoncer alors un membre
actif du disque or nous n'en attendent
pas possible c'est pas possible
ethan sayah qui n'a pas abondé contre
new year vient de battre à rio c'est
ridicule
mario qui s'est fait marcher dessus
aïe aïe aïe
il ne m'a pas venger alors bitzer 14 a
envie de suivre
10h14 que y'a blitz dans son pseudo du
coup quelque part je suis pour lui et
joue dans leurs clés rue vient mon père
juan louise n 17 tu es c'est des
sociétés les sociétés c'est ici
l'espagnol va bien bah c'est fabien
chiffres sa demande si tu pouvais peut
jouer stif ross bn commerçants tout cas
il a perdu tu voulais ouais même qu'au
maire entouré des deux côtés d'autres et
à seysses cécité opc safe il estime qu
il torée des autres shows les plus
values prison
tu passes à naulleau c'est fabián
naulleau c'est nous il complique alors
tout est possible et et 16 hockey ou
alphil deux commères effet quattro mot
claro donc la roma la rocqué si la
roquette notre la raw meat conflit cadre
lolo muchos connaisse mieux l'autre est
en train de perdre sa place entre autres
est lié avec chaque tournoi dont la la
quelle technique à attention n'ira même
pas de pattes trop documenté bravo à bel
abbès pocho gazibo ce genre de quel pays
l'ouzbékistan
je suis très très fort en rappant bravo
non mais joe cole a voulu les existants
mais en fait comme là je suis sur ton
écran de partager que son tout petit je
vaux pop
enfin là il perd la hyper la pièce
quelle horreur megan le pion imprécis
mais sa tour ici qui pousse s'il envoie
l'autre pion de l'autre côté ça devrait
le faire
tu as 3 50-3 g4 tu vois tu bouges et kat
d'abord par là et roy le karaté
tiger-cats et je crois qu'il faut pas
trop 4 je sens pas parti pour ouais mais
ça gagne aussi ce qui fait toujours
maintenant il faut qu'ils reviennent par
avec sont en fait oui je ne veux pas
donner qu on fait ça ne m'intéresse pas
je fais complètement chez devoir de
l'éruption quoi je voyais pas du tout
intéressés par cette idée bref quatre
allées ombragées 2 ouais bon hugo un
jour faudra partir d'un autre côté pour
ceux ci c'est un petit coup sur la gt3
et s'il sera pas tenté de faire bref 5
on va voir non à déjouer et ça pousse ça
pousse je pense que j'ai dit que j'ai
donné à option mes bouquins jouais bien
mais alors ce tournoi notre muse beck va
être de 20 prend un cours avec mort tu
as quoi
murtha ce que dit ni en serpent way pas
content parce que je les la bonne barré
mais je vais leur bal ainsi continuer la
vulgarité
j'ai pas vu tout le gratin peut-être
jamais les vulgarités un thé pour que
toi même tu trouves du bien j'ai déjà
activement de si jolis le chacha ce
point comme telle taille qui dit kevin
mon voeu pour hier est tout à fait en
fait je tends voudrais toute ma vie
maintenant c'est fini c'est un peu comme
les corbeaux c'est que c'est quand vous
n'oublie pas en fait un bon bah oui si
tu si tu fais une merde à un corbeau le
mec toute sa vie en fait il va il va
voir qu'un objectif c'est nuire ans
non mais vraiment se reconnaissent entre
corbeau mais ils tuent c'est qu'ils
reconnaissent les gens iraient ces gens
en fait
mais pendant des mois il sait que c'est
moi bah si tu le fais pas chier le mec
tu ignores enfin j'arrive te prends pour
une mère d'un de base il te voir marcher
j'ai eu mon site a besoin de toi moi je
vole oui vous avez vous sur un court en
vain qu'on l'a acquis on se rende marché
va zy va prendre l'avion ali dégage
vasif effet fait de féfé trois heures de
3h32 qu à marrakech je fais toi fais toi
contrôle était passeport enfin moi je
traverse je vole mais en fait si tu lui
fais une mère de bon une mère de secoirs
faire chez ces gamins en gros ou lui
prendre à bouffer baala il va sera des
toits ils vont mettre un coup de balai
ou quoi c'est même pas vrai mais il va
communiquer avec d'autres corps vous
parce qu'ils communiquent entre eux
m'ont ils ont un langage est en fait ils
vont avoir un objectif de nuire et j'ai
déjà vu des scènes mais véridique
tata le quota un corbeau qui vient il
t'a grèce un peu au visage donc tu es là
tu vois tu te défends avec tes mains et
à l'autre corbeau il vient derrière et
il te met un gros coup de bec dans le
dos et ils te font tomber coiffa tu
tombes non mais ça arrive vraiment fait
si tu attaques à 6 corbeau d'un coup tu
peux rien faire limiter très bien fait
et je lisais un truc de docteur k coup
je passe tu connais sort scientifiques
sérieux en fait c'est dr cacouna au
sérieux
s'il s'appelle bien qu'à couler non non
ça peut-être pas qu'à coup quand il
s'appelle et la série scientifique
elie kakou un grand scientifique kacou
oui michel cacouault un truc comme ça et
le mec il disait qu'en fait il voulait
étudier les corbeaux pour comprendre les
ventes l'éventualité d'une intelligence
extraterrestre miccio kacou well as cru
ce dans quoi
non non c'est un américain sur six
autres au lieu des médias russes
bon non mais il disait en fait que les
corbeaux y pense il pense pas il pense
de manière complètement différente de
nous leur servons est différent et qu'en
fait cette fois être intéressant
d'étudier l'intelligence du corbeau pour
imaginer comment les extraterrestres
pourraient penser si la mêlée des mecs
mais du coup t'es dans la merde ce que
si les mecs sont assez intelligents pour
te reconnaît toute leur vie être très
rancunier vouloir te taper sur la gueule
avec un stratagème en se mêlant à 2 pour
te taper dans le dos j'ai envie de tout
coeur l'extraterrestre j'ai pas très
envie de le rencontrer tu vois c'est
qu'il est plus groove un corbeau bah oui
vive vedette qui j'ai pas envie de dire
prise intelligente parce que s'il ya des
corbeaux qui regardent le stream ils
vont me reconnaissent et me taper sur la
gueule
donc bon aussi à des corbeaux qui écoute
les mecs on est copains façon j'ai un
sujet un nouveau chat d'ailleurs qui
vient depuis aujourd'hui chez moi donc
il n'ya pas de prénom quand je ne sais
pas comment l'appeler choc ni mallet
menus bon première fois il s'est
approché de la porte j'ai ouvert il est
reparti qu à gratter devant la porte du
vert bois il est reparti et elle a
aujourd'hui il est finalement passé le
pas mais bon il a réunifié partout il
est parti mais il est venu visiter les
noms les chats et les corbeaux comment
ça se passe bah en fait j'ai déjà lu des
histoires horribles de chat qui pouvait
plus sortir de chez eux en fait parce
qu'il avait fait une merde a encore
bojan mais vraiment en fait
non mais vraiment je rigole en fait il
avait fait une merde à un corbeau genre
les habitués leurs gamins ou quoi et les
corbeaux il s'était mis pour habiter
devant chez le chat non mais ces
histoires vraies et le shaq mais plus
sortir dès qu'ils sortaient des corbeaux
l'attaqué pour l'habitué des gages à
l'étude
est-ce que plusieurs corps beaucoup
parler
prendre le chat et s'envoler avec tu
pense pas mais je pense qu'ils peuvent
l'attaquer le défoncer moi j'ai jamais
en russie ce qui a beaucoup de corbeau à
moscou j'ai déjà vu des corbeaux sans
prendre un pigeon ouais si l'on fait un
truc mais j'ai été obligé d'aider le
pigeon en fait le pigeon était caché
dans une voiture les corbeaux a laissé
le chopper sous la voiture pour le tuer
c'était horrible
pareil ça me faisait de la peine pour le
pigeon en fait le mec avait rien fait et
complètement débile et les corbeaux là
il a dû faire quelque chose un corbeau
une fois finalement by which moi bah je
sais mais bon en fait j'ai de la peine
pour lui quoi
ok mais du coup hockey they wanted par
les corbeaux tata est digne de leurs
croix ouais on en aimerait que ce soit
ici loin des vases il était ami avec
allan ndiwa donc forcément mais sa
fonction ça me fait de la peine pour le
pour le pigeon quoi il était apeuré il
sait plus quoi faire elle était tout ça
ils communiquaient entre eux avec des
bruits tu vois et le mec il n'en pouvait
plus coiffard il était là il pas dit se
planquer sous des bannières c'est que je
valide et robots qua non mais la théorie
parce que c'est les deux mecs qui m'ont
emmerder hier pendant le tournoi donc je
suis ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre en
fait je suis pour qu'il fasse une partie
pour y poster qu'un corbeau va arriver
leur défense et leur éthique etc double
zéro les corbeaux sont arrivés des
connexions et des deux joueurs forfaits
à la prochaine ronde s'est pas non mais
c'est horrible et deux ou trois sur
trois fait c'est les deux femmes
viennent pour moi non plus je leur ai
dit sur l'arena je leur ai dit vous avez
un objectif s'ébattant de seine
tu vois c'est c'est pas des gens en fait
mais pas moins patois
non mais dr kacou mais je pense que les
gens connaissent un dr kacou oui mais
kacou que jusqu'à coup kacou 4 mais il
n'y a pas de d'araignée en français on
met pas d'accent sur un endroit esprits
en français quatre tours de 8 ans veuf
défilent au nom en d2 je pense pas
qu'ils gagnent ac et blanc
superbe tête retour des cinq déjà non tu
commences à les dominer
commune pas un problème tenir au cerveau
qui l'a vu c'était abonnés ainsi qu'aux
sur youtube six mois ça le fait marrer
je peux donner qu'à ça
dites le lui aussi l'abonné à lui moi
aussi colonel une très bon choix
je sais pas mais ça se règle en sont
quand même mieux dans cette finale
j'imagine ouais t'as d'albert c3 sera 3d
perpète
mais bon qui s'est pourtant offert un
kart avec les noirs quand même je peux
pas laisser faire à 4 à 3 avec les
blancs je veux dire 'oui' mais france tu
as un plan c c'est de cergy et 6 de foot
adam la prendre le piolot le plus haut
possible et 10 passes qui fait avec la
tempête et tu vas faire de la mef donc
avec les marche pas je vous nomme c3
j'espère te faire de déchets vient
d'abord du couloir bus est mieux ou là
ok c'est une bonne tentative pratique
d'edf le rouennais message est demandée
et dames c3 qui couvre tout cas la haye
adam français cet échec ne dorment pas
revenir vers ses 4es machin kate veut
faire g7
oui puisque photos sont floues il se
croit b2 peut-être à 3 après quoi deux
peut-être qu'il ya un sentiment un perp
est bon et la vidéo sont au tout d'r
pesticides et j'aime me humbert bêtement
des quatre des deux dames citrouilles en
c2 dans l'atome mais il y aurait pu
qu'elle faut qu'il trouve dames c'est 2
à celle de baisse malin il propose nul
incroyable je montre un roi b2 d'amour
et tu content du coup bah oui c'est nul
bah je suis content de 7000 en fait je
pense que c'est le meilleur résultat qui
pouvait m'arriver en fait en sept
parties mario qui a gagné raphaël
diddy qui se débrouille pas mal et
didier info
allez faut mettre au four mettre sa tour
en un set il faut jouer un tonton
maintenant c'est la meilleure nul que je
pouvais avoir je trouve que c'est bien
qu'ils aient fait nul avec un joueur qui
était gagnant à les tours à cette tonton
autour des 7 pas mal aussi
sacre attendu sur la pendule quoi
directive retour des deux mais trois
petits peut faire c'est 3-1 en s
échouent un seul gagnant ça pour les
noirs ou pas peut-être pas emmené est à
tour en sept ans on aurait pu commencer
par a3 aussi tout ce à quoi ils ont je
pense souvent c'est nul c'est juste en
fait un moment qu père d'elia farman ans
oui mais géré par la juste avant mais
y'a 4 où l'homme bon je sais que ce qui
est tout à rien mais je n'ai plus trop
si les blancs sont mieux dans les pions
sont plus là en fait déjà et c'est
peut-être mieux d'avoir l'euro en
défense en plus peut-être tombé ici cela
voilà temps de six tours à 4 heures je
pense qu'il arrive en premier oui
logiquement ils dérangent davance et
gagne encore attendre il attendra le
pion c'est beaucoup de choses
ok peut-être n'est pas au bout de nos
surprises
j'ai trouvé cela très essais afin de
surprise est nul
dans le truc sans voix et couper ça va
être chaud à cette concurrence ou quiero
gh3 quoi il a tenté mais mes tours à
s'être refroidie n'en sortent pas mal
non bourges et de voeux tizi chaîne
non mais c'est pas encore d'accord juge
sait pas si on va au bout de toutes nos
surprises tant saada mais en même temps
c'est chaud toujours avantage aux blancs
qui ont les chèques non plus voir un
homme de plus et ils veulent ouais ça
est fini a donné quatre échecs au
prochain qe même sens c'était chaud et
du coup c'est les blancs qui ont montré
à celle de beast a été ton regard de bob
la truffe contre et ain taya monsieur
mais plutôt pour moi que la truck du
goût et n 5 qui va être en pls en fait
jamais pour lui se règle bon moi j'ai
rien contre lui
bah si la rhénane hier c'est quand même
pas contents ou merguez ou l'autre mais
après c'est vrai qu'il s'est bien remis
enfin il essaye d'être dans l'esprit en
fait en fait ils choisissent qui ils
sont fous de tout quoi en fait c'est à
lui n'a aucune aucune conscience l'eau
tu ton stream
ils sont fichus elle mais qu'elle à
partir partent du temps il veut tendre
avec moi enfin tu vas face à la vue
c'est peut-être petit troll voyait un
peu comme un espèce de psychose et
d'échecs quoi tu écoutes les gens
partout
en fait il est pas mal déjà un foot les
lycées 6 dame b 6
le truc en fait tu ne peux pas ne pas
être pour les noirs ici malheureusement
même si on était contre lui en fait on
est obligés d'être pour ce qui fait
c'est trop beau là pour le moment c'est
tellement les blés peau échec qu'on aime
alors encore un coup de bons moule qui
échangent en d4 nom duquel est parti en
a trois avec le plus nuancée 3 pourquoi
pas quoi la logique là dedans dans les
fers dame prend à la tourache intentions
mais c'est le petit jeu ça ait changé
d'âme
mais bon même jusqu'à laisser 600 photos
même finale oui mais bon papa tu as plus
de dames
non mais bon tas d'autres choses
l'intériste 15h les dames si je voulais
partir comme ça c'est pour avoir des
dames pour se faire chier dans final ni
subi quoi mais du coup moi je joue un
peu comme ça tu vas dans l'aréna avec
les noirs je joue comme ça très vite et
je fus un bordel pas possible les mecs
en pls et en fait je joue sur le fait
que je vais gagner beaucoup plus vite en
[ __ ] un bordel pas croyable enfin
c'est mon c'est mon objectif
les menaces faux et 4 quand même hein ça
peut refroidir géniale cette expression
de mathieu cornette ça te refroidi
j'adore vraiment marrant non
oui ps si j'étais refroidi je suis du
sud 0 tient douteux refroidi je passe il
est mis au pas l'air bon c'est pas mais
ce que sera content
j'espère que mercredi prochain dans
l'aréna ce sera pas ce sera pas en scène
le chat bramer mais le végal non ok
c'est le 6 et le boucher vega n'y avait
pas de match mais enfin on a compris que
j'étais quand même gros favoris
mais un bulletin de ses shows coiffure
et c'est non mais ça me fait pas peur
mais gérard par la queue il un poil plus
fortement à lormont mégère théoriquement
je peux dépasser à bolton bâle doit quoi
on sera un désaveu quoi de ne pas finir
devant bolton quoi ouais après il faut
voir comment il faut reconnaître mais
mais bon c'est faisait comment ça quoi
paladin fois j'ai fini j'ai fini la fois
qu'on a fait aux enfants je suis ni 23
places devant comme un fou bon voilà ce
qui est normal quoi mais en fait les
très très bien que le remonter peut-être
h4 non pour se débarrasser du problème
une petite tour qui devrait commencer
par acre 4 bon c'est vrai que toi tu
fais naturellement j'aurais pas aimé
filets ce fut en fait comment quand et
pourquoi donner sculptures de leur
arrestation h4h 3 et toi tu fait tordre
et à tout rachat
on me l'a juste où vicky domaine qu en
fait ils payent engagé dans la dernière
fois c'était à refaire je te trouvais
retour à schwyz g705 pas grave je crois
ouais c'est chaud kg cède 3,5
hk qui on prend effet nommer le prochain
jeu pour voir si tu qu'un futur h 7 h 14
septembre au 8 mai a pu sortir que non
mais h4 prises elles font des bronzes la
dame mais du coup là le cavalier
peut-être perdu en fait ben oui mais
c'est pour ça qu'il est juste de spawn
coutelle 5 3 et 6 mai prochains dans ce
qu'il est trop mal fc oui les trois
jours à detroit un jeu trop impulsif 9
5e
bon après tu fais trois cas ok mais il
faut il encore faire f 5 épreuves cinq à
prier prier de fait prendre garde
qu'est-ce que ça bon gars ont regagné en
rond ce débat on a des surprises tout le
temps s'est jamais attaqué et bien
qu'ils aient prouvé deux camps même
voiliers mais attendre il va pas faire
non c'est sûr trop compliqué bah vu
l'enchaînement de coûts est bon quel
projet trois votes il faire en fait
c'est un truc que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre femmes
c'est pourquoi compte est plus fort en
finale il ya une beaucoup plus grande
différence de niveau qu'en milieu de jeu
en fait lambeets en tout cas c'est plus
le client final
non mais je comprends pas parce que du
coup quelle idée hein c'est une
fourchette en un coup quand même période
pourquoi est-ce qu en milieu de jeu ils
peuvent te planter en tactique et en
finale il ya une telle différence de
deux niveaux en fait j'ai déjà remarqué
plein de fois que en finale la
différence de niveau est plus pourquoi
je sais pas en fait même mais en fait le
mieux jo tu joues un peu au hasard
puisque apparaît lors de la division
global de la position tu sens un peu le
truc et tu faire mais au final tu fais
ça ça n'a juste pas c'est trop important
tué hier qu en milieu de jeu tu peux
mais tu peux jouer des coups sans
vraiment être sûr que ça va tenir loin
des raisons que t'as pas prévu quoi
ouais t'as de la chance en finale en
fait la valeur découvre plus importante
une faute au final plus perdre il faut
tant mieux de jeu de ta -0 20 ce que
c'est grave je resterai pas faire que
des finales supprimer milieu de parcours
non mais par contre qu avec l'avant
c'est une stratégie classique coach des
films de jean raffard juste pour gagner
sans risque mais du moins fort non mais
le problème c'est les parties lentes
parce qu'en partie lente en fait sinon
une finale trop simple ok quoi peut-être
que n'importe qui peut de fernand beats
non
mario qui va pas réussir à battre cette
the best je pense parce que pions - mais
fou ouais mais c'est lui qui joue pour
nous le cavalier effet un espèce de
barrière de corail sur le problème quand
et du corail mais sa balle et noir non
mais déjà les noirs ont pas gagné lors
des 4e tête d'air france ça c'est sûr
turan est loin des 4 fers cavaliers
detroit c5 ça va être froid dire un jour
mêmes droits qu'à terre bouge échanges à
rodez 4 ou qu'est l'e3 un jour un coup
n'importe tu le refroidir et en fait je
vais mettre le quart ayant des cinq
épandez trois peut-être qu'ils échangent
des cas âgé de 5o non le vin mais si on
peut aller prendre l'a6 mais bon j power
tech mais j'avais pas très envie en fait
d'échangés comme ça finalement
alors tu réflexion faite j'ai envie de
laisser d'essayer de laisser des
plongées 3g trois autres ça c'est
merdique qui a gagné en fait un mot
qu'elle a fermé des six mois ces cinq
croit la calle bessette et poussé aux
possibilités peut-être c'était g4 bref 4
600 g 3 kg buter points trois points je
crois qu il précise je tiens ton truc et
est 7 e mail au range étroit et ouais
mais tu mon tour je sais pas dans quelle
époque là c'est peut-être possible
non mais là ok ça tu peux te faire
contre bonbons dont je vous ai pas à
cette là je pense il faut décaler des 5
aimer ça se tenait la danse passion ok
peut-être une perdante
quelle faute barragan et 5 avant kiev 5
ok bah pranger devant une foule loin
c'est horrible mais une nouvelle fois en
coin je crois les pousse les finales ça
ne pardonne pas non mais
ok moi j'ai qu'un essai 7 ou 8 mange
mange je sors web 3g trois noms mais
choix de cette fermeté tranche non mais
tu vas faire h trois cavaliers prend 1,8
g deux cavaliers bouge
moi j'ai trop encourager 3 ou comme ça
qu'est et bouffe que le courage de
vraies mais relève 3 3 non mais c'est
gagné
ok je crois oui oui enfin peu importe le
plus
dans oz et au parquet de faire caler g3
aussi après de fer qui avait fait 5 et
g3 mc alger 3 c'était mal hein oui mais
si tu le prends pas beaucoup de fous je
fais roi mérovingien lagostina partout
ok h 4 h cup et chaque émeute mais en
fait c'était pareil de faire ça en fait
ok ok tu fais peut-être wife 3 en fait
ouais ok kaïro par ouais ouais mais nous
qui la traverse à 2h du matin est ce que
je peux voir sur le cac suis
intelligente yh2 prochain bref 2 juin
des bombes a bien joué bon du coup ça
décida peut-être le tournant ça c'est
fini il reste sinon je crois y ait un
sac kaki à faire une ruine voyage est un
élève
bon il va jouer un tour assez sérieux et
touba le mec il me dit rien mais dans le
corps il fait foule au risk of un fou
mais en fait j'ai pas toulon le dit que
tout le monde parle comme nous en fait
mon nom du monde hibou la méthode
ruisseau entre une robe g4 à tout va des
gages en faudrait 10 avoli tu joues tout
me parle comme ça en jette
[Rires]
bon ben ça y est les birds c'est pas
tant que chargé quatre quoi tu nous
grauby fils et ruiz quoi ni veut ça 4 à
dabul
non mais il se fait pardonner quand même
et c'est quoi cette deuxième chat n'a
que tard je vous prends un celi james
comme des briseurs chat qui on est sur
tous les fronts alors
ouais c'est pas mal d'amis ses pions sur
la troisième il a bien une petite pointe
en 4 je te mord la queue
tamer tout ira bien le petit piranha ce
t4 qua non mais à ruiz c'est pas une
réouverture en fait enfin attention sur
les pions sur blanche n'est plus tout
cas se mange et ses 3 f 5 dans votre
matelas fin attention au blitz arcade
mia blitz en sont donc forcément je sais
que tu es un petit faible même attention
non mais light and steria le truc c'est
que moi j'ai pas j'ai pas répond il est
complètement leader du tournoi et 4 et
demi sur cinq
mais ces choses position ce sorbet prend
il est peut-être qui est j 4 il a pris
deux des mets du cloud tsephel ordonne b
sat et tous les domaines
oui mais bon tu es tu tiens tout d'abord
à temps pour un sacre un sacre a nié
qu'il prend 1,4 sur kevin quand bien
même battu par lyon ça vous n'avez pas
pensé qu'on prend 4 il faut faire c'est
pas mal aussi
tu as the prend 2,5 à peut-être fait
réussissent avec les blancs non mais
c'est un peu la crise comme fort non
mais j'ai pas pu être sans voix le pion
aux oeufs et ouais tu pris fin après ses
rangs la merde parce que c'est déjà pas
mal ya cinq ans fait et c'est tant pis
tu le prends en foudre entre tomber un
accroche toi
telle une sangsue à ta position est
situé au 600 membres et adidas ranger et
6 aussi madame d'un projet ici c'est
peut-être ça le refroidit sénat ouais
j'aurais sûrement fait dans le projet 6
mais bon ok même là c'est justement une
un projet si c'était chaud enfin tu as
quand même attendre mais il faudra
mettre un truc quand même s'ils se
marient mais bon du coup tu te prends ça
enfin sara lee s'est quand même d'aller
piranha qui adore
ok prend prend un tour bien les défendre
et attaquer les f4 et au pied quoi ça
joue ouais mais monte en coin 53.5 les
échelons attention donc m6 vérité vient
peut-être que 10,4 contre attaque
bon en fait ça va voilà j'aurai pas pris
là tout en fait j'aurais continué
attaque karim matos
piranha piranha un tintin avec f4 parti
ça va ça va ça vient si parce que le
pion de moins bon on s'en fout mais on
sait les blancs qui attaquent les un
truc d'hommes détroit qui peut arriver à
tout moment
en plus pour vendre ajouté dans la place
yann moix vos questions ce parc
clemenceau mieux objectivement mai mais
bon si chaud j'ai chaud tout à relancer
on ne sait pas des choses à tous les
étages
quels tournois haletant non mais c'est
pas ma faute j'aurais bien balancé b5
vos midi servi à tuer pas balancer des
singles husson vice champion vous en
envoie juste va peut-être pourquoi pas
quoi pu être le pion sais tu t'en fous
quand il fait quelque 3 ou 5 et penser
4' teyssèdre volonté du dante 3 quoi tu
le refroidit mr freeze moins licites
non je préférais carte du referee quatre
femmes ont été mes futurs refroidir ou
quoi quoi ben khalfallah catch se
refroidit pas ce que tu me fais tu fais
ces trois tu fais dans le détroit
je ne sais pas jutting 3 d'abord pour
cette dame des tables de bon enfin
pourquoi pas et je te refroidi
différemment et mieux c'est être pas mal
donc c'est pesant
notre dame c3
m le kenyan des cinq j'imagine ça peut
être à ça à 4 à 4 à 5 machines avancent
futur j'aimerais bien mettre la musique
de de texas ranger les outils toulouse
où je suis pas là dessus de pain là je
peux pas keith b 6
j'ai tout donné mais banques et si on va
perdre mais kate façon je crois que moi
jamais rater ces trucs
ben non mais je pense qu'il changeait
d'âme c'était une faute la fal tas je
crois qu'ils les red light les noirs à
huit cercles et peut-être si ces trois
jeux de la merde au sud soit encore
notre foi en russie serait on ne sait
pas
m ux égalité noir tu peux rien faire les
pions sont trop mauvais temps mais
j'aime bien la musique de walker texas
ranger son pote nazis siffle un peu je
sais plus exactement comment recife je
suis très beau ici fleurs est bon non
mais je sais même pas français comme un
karaoké belle époque et pas de portes
non mais si si si qui fait presque juste
que je pense que tu avec nuri sahin
peuvent là tu vois quelque part enfin
c'est un peu la même chose quoi pas on
inférieur évidemment mais genre dans
l'esprit tu vois d'un coup je me dis que
la chanson du walker texas ranger c'est
un peu la chanson de l'add on inférieur
on inférieur évident à tel aviv est
super à chuck
non mais c'est pas si simple cette
finale a du coup le roi a réussi à
monter il a pendant qu'ici le pur eux
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il quand tu fais sort en
f1 non mais pourquoi de référents jk je
trouve quand même que youtube et ça ok
bon voilà c'est en prod2 dirait du coup
fruits le futur proche de juste pour
gagner mais là qu'est ce que c'est que
cette horreur
ouais c'est dingue c'est finalement
ketura 3 et reprend ses 3 et games à
3pts être ok moi je serais tu reprends
ses 3 5 - g41 personne je me casserais
pas trop la tête mais ok tout reprendre
pour penser troyes vannes en trouver
deux même si dont la déviation
en fait j'ai du mal à gagner autrement
quand juste en balançant à calloc'h en
gagnant le truc bas du cou et anne sayah
dommage belles parties qui joue pas très
bien les finales en fait faut le dire il
joue pas mal mais les finales c'est son
talon d'achille
son funeste au talon d'achille j'ai
envie de dire mais bon victor deux
seules joies quoi il ya la médaille d'or
enfin cette joie qui profite de la
victoire de blitz arbitraire qui fit
troisième est en-deçà deuxième hockey
bravo c'était un mouton noir
tout est bon mais voilà à quoi bon
voyage aller voir un peu l'om ce qu'ils
font de l'élevage d'ânes ou le score bah
ouais j'éteins la télé quand je peux me
connecter à l'équipe ou quoi mais se
dire ça non mais demain je préviens si
d'état
il était bien il devait gagner
l'émission fait que même nul suffise à
le gain du tournoi
bah oui il a perdu ça en fait elle a
donné sa tour wpt est meilleur pour la
fin je convoite ski afrique avec son roi
aussi enfin je sais pas avait encaissé
le pion j'ai faim j'ai pas fais des
trucs quoique la méta tour ans et 5e et
à tours angers 5 en cash champions
revient en casse l'option et gagne quoi
alors l'om fait 0 0 l'atletico madrid
mène à 0 par le portugal latcho drom
salzburg
un partout arsenal cska moscou 3-1 pour
l'un ce titre porte et auxquelles et
tombe à écouter mon autre aux autres
jeux on se retrouve ce week end sera
bien le prochain 6 passes ont fait une
vidéo de présentation pour la pour la
finale les demies et la finale
un look ce sera qui leur a alors donné
moi enfin on redira dans la vidéo sur
youtube
je crois que c'est de 20h à 1h du matin
en quelque chose comme ça samedi et puis
après on y plonge donc grosse soirée
robin williams mois il vient et on se
retrouve là hasta luego sur quoi dans le
tweet ou sur youtube l'on sait pas on
sera surtout il se sera sur cette chaîne
la même mais on est tout seul sida mais
on peut retrouver sur la chaîne du
stream aussi parce qu'elle sera host est
un parti pour votre pronostic pour
entrer sur toutes les chaînes tweaks un
désavantage de twitch par rapport à
youtube c'est que tu peux avancer pas
excusé m sur plusieurs chaînes devraient
donc c'est cette fin ces pratiques la
vidéo fait plusieurs chaînes en même
temps au caire on suivra ce avec
internet
ok les tontons you do